And my answer is quite simple--again, it runs my experiment a 1000 times using the for x in range
it summons a new list and this on the list is the mean of the list produced by flip.
Flip itself every single time I run it will give me a 1000 0s or 1s or truths or false
and using the function mean, I compute the mean of that.
But now I have an outer loop where I do this calculation of the mean a 1000 times.
It summed them into a new list and that's my new list and that list is continuous valued.
These are printed out by saying print outcomes after generating it.
What I see is a list of 1000 numbers--it all have around some by 0.5,
some of it is 0.046, some is 0.515.
These are the empirical means for these sequences of a 1000 coin flips.
See how it flip effectively 1,000,000 coins here, and this is the corresponding histogram
plotting the frequency of the coins.
[#000000]